[Music]
20:18 has been the year of the underdog
in eSports across every game across
every scene the underdog triumphed this
past year from cloud 9 and csgo
[Applause]
a major champion - OG in DotA 2
[Applause]
- Invictus gaming in league of legends
2018 world champions the underdog came
out on top time and time again in 2018
sure sometimes the top dog did win out
to beat to be called the best but across
every game every scene the underdogs
came to play the teams and players that
few believed in and even fewer predicted
to win defeated their personal goliaths
and triumphed on some of the biggest
stages that eSports has to offer and
it's not just in the biggest games
either nearly every eSport saw an
underdog win out whether it was over a
veteran opponent an entire region or
even the major esports themselves in
every game in every scene in every
eSport 2018 was the year of the underdog
[Music]
these are their stories
[Music]
cs:go got the year of the underdog off
to a wild start as the scene wasted no
time debating who would take the crown
at January's Boston major virtus Pro
were in the midst of what seemed like a
return to form a straw Louis were widely
considered to be one of the scenes best
teams and faze clan looked like the
super team to beat
and then there was cloud nine going into
the Boston major I mean it was business
as usual and as far as na is concerned I
think which unfortunately means little
to no hope liquid wasn't looking
especially special c9 was absolutely I
think far from anybody's mind in terms
of winning this thing or making it
particularly far I think leading up to
the major phase clan in particular was
on quite a tournament tear they were the
only ones winning but na was nowhere to
be found and I feel like this was phases
major to win it was their destiny to win
it almost felt like was a done deal one
point and given Enys history at the
majors few fans had any expectations for
the region's best team with a clean 3o
record in the new challenger stage clown
I move forward to the new legend stage
this time though things didn't go so
well with an O n to record clown dine
looked like they would be sent packing
I just seemed like a done deal right I
mean people were writing the eulogy
before the team was even six feet under
you already had nothing on the desk in
Boston
saying hey look you know the problems
that happened when I left are obviously
still there but with their major lives
at stake everything changed
cloud9 went into their next matches
against VP a stralla and Vega squadron
and did the unthinkable two veces false
Maxim Pasha
doing all they can no weapon for them to
collect plays through the smoke
automatic here and there's a lost player
Pasha in the Reds there he goes and
there there you go so they've put
themselves in position where they can
get some information they can quickly
rotate to each bomb site both of them
with eyes on a sigh grinder Manchu all
they spotted him they definitely knew
one dares to kill 16:6 Estrada's sent
packing from cloud nine who continued
into the tournament could do this please
go no kit donates and he's gotta find
two kills which these polar opposites
yeah good tires 180 again though the HPI
jumps across rush nails at sixteen
rounds for cloud nine cloud nine to the
table eight
with those three wins c9 made it back to
the bracket and they were determined not
to let it go to waste now body is so
much trouble the Kenny's gonna be up
high ground getting the kill it almost
went down himself there's body picking
it up and now it's a 1vs1
tstewy versus candy the smell of gunfire
and freedom in there
picking up that hill back south night
menace semi-finals
oh my god what a story they've shut down
t to almost rule is leaving what can you
even do about that now flashbang comes
out and they do rush down Poland that's
gonna be a lot of trouble gets down as
well cloud9 answering back to magic with
the kill just like that
Conine in the one roses fall taco can't
do anything about safety
with the hometown crowd at their backs
cloud9 did would only one any team has
ever done before and competed in a major
final and they wouldn't stop there he
must be like Stewie it's going
absolutely crazy on the box nothing else
is going on he's gonna go back just by
staying there
[Music]
classic
why
do you know what that noise means that
it means it's match point cloud nine so
from this position before you cannot
miss a single shot Guardian waits
patiently as crowd my scepter push up
[Applause]
Oh chopper
I mean the grand final for the Boston
major was unreal personally I would
consider one of the best major Grand
Finals of all time I don't think that's
a particularly controversial opinion in
retrospect I guess no one knew what to
expect but I'm gonna be real with you I
don't think I was alone in thinking that
this is a done deal for phase clam you
know we're just watching the clock
waiting for that
that's 1610 that 1612 scoreline but
that's not how it played out
even when the confetti was falling up I
could hardly believe it the rest of the
year was less kind to see us goes
underdogs Astralis went on to dominate
the scene with five premier tournament
wins including a first place finish at
2018 other major but another underdog
story did emerge in London as complexity
defied the odds by not only qualifying
for the major but making it out of the
new challengers stage when it comes to
complexity ahead of the London major I
really don't think they were on
anybody's radar in any way I mean this
is an org that has not been
internationally relevant in CS for four
or five years you have to go way back to
2013 or there abouts to find them making
any kind of run at a valve major the
intense training regimen warden the
former legend Rambo one of the most
historic North American counter-strike
players of all time as the coach of this
team and they're gonna be making it to
the legends stage Jason Lake what are
the first real owners in eSports as a
whole this palm plant isn't even gonna
go down and yeas done it who better to
close it out and it still seems like
they just say can't even believe it
themselves what a what a great story
this is well the team ultimately fell
short in the bracket they went further
than anyone expected them to and secured
themselves a spot in the upcoming
Katowice major sure na may have only won
one major in 2018 but clown IDEs win
coupled with complexity Cinderella run
proves that you can never count out the
underdog
League of Legends is rarely kind to the
underdog for years the International
competitive scene has been dominated by
South Korea a region that won five
straight World Championships between
2013 and 2017 Korea is definitely the
most historically dominant region we've
ever seen in league of legends
regardless of what happened this year I
think you look at the history of the
game the way that they were able to set
the meta the way that every other region
felt like they needed to play around
what Korea was doing and there really
was a gap you know it's a meme but it
was truth that was it there was a
noticeable gap but 2018 not only ended
the streak it also marked a turning
point for the games competitive scene
while the second half did the first half
of the year didn't provide too many
surprises King's Own dominated the lck
to a point where fans had to plan around
the extra time they got from their
lightning quick series and things
weren't too different in the games other
regions which is why all eyes were on
Korea heading into the midseason
Invitational
but Roy will never give up through the
world for a loop
karela duty to fix him up the feathers
are goes back and forth the show who
dies
Susie keeps our in GLI time
Jason
well I'm definitely say orange ease win
at msi was huge it felt like orangey
were just sort of a step ahead of kings
own the whole time and this was a king's
own team that people saw as heavy
favorites going into the tournament they
were so dominant in korea and whenever a
team has been dominant in korea
historically the safe bet is an analyst
has been to say well they're gonna win
whatever international tournament is
whether it's msi whether it's worlds you
know the the dominant korean team are
always odds on favorites but there was
still a lot of fans of Korean League or
analyst students of the game people
saying you know what one tournament is
at the end of the world it's not the
first time that Korea's lost at MSI and
come Worlds it won't be one Korean team
it'll be three I think a lot of people
still felt like there was no way that
Korea could lose at the back end of the
season and the upsets didn't stop there
China also defeated a South Korean All
Star team at the Asia Games and back in
North America
cloud9 were putting together a historic
world's round
heading into the summer split the 2018
summer split cloud9 made a really bold
decision which was to bench three of
their star players they benched sneaky
they benched Jensen and did they bench
Smoothie what cloud nine and rebored and
their staff said at the time was that
these players weren't motivated they
weren't performing and scrims and behind
the scenes but to fans it seemed really
drastic but with some smart roster moves
creative play and perseverance they took
that road as far as it could go
and beer to get the kill the trade back
though huge napkin can they secured the
night well Gilchrist inky they're all
falling now TSM are routed they're
inside their face the Nexus will come
bring out the silver scripts we're going
to Game five joining here comes up five
five five
is this the one that ends it all great
getting away burning down trying to stay
alive to for Sarah cloud9 and they get
changed in the opening hymn and old
fortress biggie they get
two three four zero
the game a 69
and though they lost the summer finals
to Team Liquid plow nine bounced back
for the regional finals over there but
cloud nine weren't the only team putting
on a show at Worlds after years of
playing third fiddle to South Korea and
China the European teams have made their
mark on the tournament as well with both
g2 esports and fnatic advancing to the
quarterfinals and while vitality the
third European team of the tournament
fell their coach Yamato cannon rallied
the region and asked that they stay true
to their own style and stand together
against the East g2 when they showed up
in the style they're winning when fnatic
are doing best out there winning just
stayed true to yourselves do not try to
chase anyone to try to copy anyone just
be confident don't limit yourselves
either go into this tournament play your
next games believing that you can win
everything that is the mentality you
need to have to conquer the best because
anything is possible if you just believe
and play with confidence and stay true
to yourselves so do that for me Europe
please when the dust settled
not a single Korean team made
to the top four with the upsets out of
the way the rest of the tournament went
how most expected with IG and fnatic
playing in the finals and IG stomping
them in short order 2018-2019 is set to
be the most exciting year league has
ever seen and it's all thanks to the
underdogs for much of 2018 dota 2 was a
game dominated by just a handful of
teams Team Liquid the International 2017
champions broke the post TI curse and
became the first TI winning team in
history to have a strong host victory
season actually done it thank God
you're champions but a China dota 2
super major Team Liquid PSG LGD won
back-to-back majors and didn't fall
below top three in a major from April
until the end of the year I got kind of
sick of repeating that these guys were
by far the best in the tournament and I
thought they were gonna win every game
what a team
honestly they make that signing picking
up x anova and bringing him into the
fold and ever since then they have
looked like one of the most dominant if
not the most dominant team in all of
China and virtus Pro winners of four
majors were so dominant that their
players won three mercedes-benz's from
ESL as MVP prizes going into TI 8 those
were the teams on everyone's lists to
hoist the ages have a least that's what
everyone thought going into TI 8 o Qi
were ranked dead last in popular
rankings before the super err major they
had lost fly in s4
who were considered to be in the form of
s4 their most mechanically skilled and
experienced player himself a TI winner
and fly who really was their captain
this kind of collective team mindset
they had this team was generally
speaking considered to be the weakest
team @ti despite going into the
tournament as the lowest ranked team Oh
G made it through the group stage and
into a faded showdown with eg the team
that put them in their dire position by
signing two of their best players ahead
of Ti
let's get the kill
he's gone already feel a finish
[Music]
it was chilling you could literally hear
the collective groan throughout the
arena as these two former best friends
of 14 years just became the locus of all
of the tension and drama over the last
few months in just that one second when
they passed by each other and no tale
having come on you know beat beat fly
which no one anticipated really gave him
this opportunity to just grin stand over
his former friend and just stare right
into his soul oh gee then moved on to
the upper bracket finals where they
faced down one of the strongest teams
left standing and in an incredible
display of skill patience and fortitude
og kept finding ways to come back from
the brink
at Cal Thomson heat up the racks needs
up the ring the timing nice from the
Cataclysm but into your armor with the
actors bothering forward
play G right the Savior
Gina to get to the grand final party
TIPA TIPA more finish the game
with a 2-1 victory they moved on to the
grand finals where they once again faced
off against LGD this time though the
series went to five games Jade's the
record across don't get the kill to
Japanese in the middle using himself
with the flame God kicking it for the
son of this RG they fight three they
look to one some of the surrounding in
the pits of this he'll go down as well
ami he's miss proud the stole efficient
for jerks alitempleton with a slap
ending it up no it's not LGD that wants
to yet again but they have managed to
fight to return and is still alive the
flame guard keep it in fight again the
side of [ __ ] cuts down the second
double kill for Ana
Charlie's surrounded by seven on air in
the trees as
get the cheese wine with
done
[Applause]
chickens
oh gee lifted the ages marking the end
of the most incredible run in dota 2
history and the likely changing the way
people approach dota twos endgame
forever I think that og proved that the
roster that you have going into the
tournament doesn't need to be your
biggest concern I think they prove that
it's very easy to sit around and say
things like well we play to the bitter
end or we never give up or you know we
are warriors and fighters they didn't
just play to the bitter end they just
didn't see the end to begin with and I
think that they taught every other
professional team at that tournament a
lesson in what it actually means to
never ever ever stop fighting
winning a tournament isn't the only
marker of a successful underdog story
last year we ended the story of 2017
wondering how the overwatch league would
perform in a world traditionally
dominated by three major eSports we saw
a game that from like from the early
point people expected to be this like
giant in eSports and then we had like a
little hitch for a while turn into the
game like everybody expected to it to be
people got excited about the teams and
the players in a way that they hadn't
previously and gave people an
opportunity to like see the game on the
stage that they expected to see it when
it came out the overwatch League has
found success the viewership
on the season one Grand Finals didn't
beat out the 2018 League of Legends
World Championship this year but it did
beat out both the na and EU LCS summer
finals viewership and over the course of
the entire year
overwatch League viewership compared
favorably for the NA LCS as viewership
there are a lot of existing eSports fans
watching the overwatch League but it
also seems to have a wide audience
outside just endemic hardcore eSports
fans I think that there's definitely
something exciting about the game that
maybe takes a little bit less investment
to get into then then what like we've
traditionally seen the eSports and like
sort of the way that they've been
replicating that traditional sports
style of like getting behind a logo and
a brand so I think that it's working and
in that capacity at least a little bit
meanwhile another game has seen success
catering to fans who aren't necessarily
the traditional eSports audience for
tonight which launched its battle royale
mode last year quickly became the most
popular game in the West and a streaming
juggernaut which led many in the eSports
community to ask if it could ever become
a viable competitive eSport I really
don't think that people had high hopes
and I mean there's always been
criticisms of battle Royales as eSports
that's like kind of a difficult format
to replicate in a competitive sense you
know there can be some some random
aspects that make it difficult to be
a high-level so I think that people were
very skeptical of a foreigner from the
beginning when we saw this game blow up
and then it was like okay how do we make
this competitive so yeah I'm not sure
people expected for it to work but the
game was too big to leave alone as Epic
Games stepped in to pour tens of
millions of dollars into the game's
competitive scene the eSports experience
for both spectators and players improved
and super stars were born hands-down the
the most sort of successful players in
the eSports scene are the face guys
cloaks and antifa this year we saw the
way that fortnight can be dominated at a
high level that I don't I honestly don't
think anybody expected I think the
community has really rallied behind them
as these kind of sort of heroes of early
fortnight days so I mean those guys are
really sort of paving the way for fans
to get behind eSports and for a
fortnight the game is not an underdog at
least in 2018 fortnight the East Ward on
the other hand grew in fits and started
to become one of the scenes biggest
games despite doubt from the eSports
community
fighting games are the scene where
underdogs thrive Open bracket
tournaments mean that everyone gets an
equal shot at glory no Auto qualify
players no guaranteed results the only
thing that's standing between you and
the trophy are the other players in your
bracket and nowhere was that more
evident than Evo it boasts every game's
biggest bracket and the world's top
players making it a hotbed for underdog
stories super smash bros melee has
always been dominated by a small handful
of players for much of its competitive
existence the five gods Armada hungrybox
mew2king
mango and ppmd eventually gave way to a
handful of new players but evo the
hardest tournament of the year was a
god's turned Evo is the hardest
tournament in the world to win no matter
what game you are playing at Evo right
it is the biggest tournament in the
world for any of these games usually and
you know if you are the let's say even
the eighth best player in the world
you become something of an underdog
because you're gonna have to meet the
seventh best the sixth to fifth mess the
fourth best the third best the second
best and the best in order to win you
have to go through so many matches
back-to-back and you're gonna end up
playing sure you'll start playing
against the weaker players but you're
gonna end up playing against the other
seven best players in the world once
you're in top eight the year started off
with a really incredible bang of Plouffe
winning Genesis but after that it was
hungrybox hungrybox hungrybox armada
retired and it was just hungry box is
gonna win evo but there were other
contenders Plouffe that was looking
really strong and people also had a lot
of thoughts about Mango who was kind of
playing in form again which was which
was surprising to some people and really
exciting for his fans
but you know everybody the safe money
hungry box and the grand finals and
hungrybox probably wanting it because of
that many thought of leffen the first
player to be all five gods as an
afterthought to win people didn't think
he missed top eight but he wasn't in the
grand finals conversation
at least that was the perception up
until winners quarterfinals their Levin
beat one of his biggest threats
hungrybox and moved on to the winners
finals where he demolished the race and
in speedrunning or in melee won
everything with two of the tournament
favorites knocked out only one opponent
was standing between leffen and Mae
Lee's biggest prize Armada and well
lapin dismantled his fellow countryman
[Music]
[Applause]
super smash brothers melee champion
leffen the first non-god player to win
melee at evo since 2013 lifted the
trophy that had evaded him for so long
lesson winning was you know shocking
right him beating hungrybox was shocking
him beating clump was impressive they're
not a crazy surprise and but how many
got two armada it was like a lesson is
playing better than anybody else is
playing today and that that makes all
the difference in the world
leffen lifting that trophy in front of
as many eyes as a melee could possibly
have in 2018 tells people that lesson is
in contention for the best in the world
that a non gon player is in contention
for the best player in the world and
that is a just a sea change for melee
but he wasn't the only underdog to win
that day later that evening all eyes
were on Toki doe the defending Evo
champion was on a tear throughout the
2018 season no one looks stronger and no
one looked like more of a lock to
Evo than toki doh you know a lot of
people had their eyes on tokyo tokyo was
looking so good and was playing so well
and there are other japanese players
people had their eyes on people were
looking at the aegyo thing really strong
people looking at Sakho as being really
strong and a lot of people did overlook
our actual eventual champion problem ex
problem x is one of if not now the best
player in europe but he's part of a long
line of europe strong players who on the
international stage have done well but
never aside from one spectacularly
people just didn't see him coming
problem x ran through a difficult
bracket defeating the likes of banchan
Fujimura luffy and gotcha cook and when
he came against Fudo he only narrowly
took the win
he is going to grand final over food in
the grand finals he found himself face
to face with taquito who tore through
the lower bracket for another crack at
the championship okay problem X became
the first European Street Fighter Evo
champion since 2014 and the first-ever
from the UK between him and leffen this
year showed off the very best of the FG
C's underdogs there are two kinds of
players who play professional Starcraft
two Koreans and the rest of the world
much like League of Legends Koreans
dominate Starcraft competitive scene but
unlike League no one else really matters
North America Europe China they're all
foreigners they're all one big pile of
non Koreans who don't win the important
tournaments at least not until this year
starting in January
seral a young finish third player won
every single WCS stop he attended
we've seen moments where foreigners have
shown a lot of promise they've gone to
Korea boot camp live the Korean
lifestyle and team home and they've made
some progress in the European and North
American scene however their wins
against Koreans were always so far and
few at GSL vs. the world
seral triumphed beating three Korean
players in a row to take first place the
world champion he took out best player
in every race he is the best in the
world right now ladies and gentlemen and
then at Blizzcon Saral defied the odds
again coming in on top of a bracket
build with top korean talent the brood
lords starting to get picked off here as
well though he comes in once more he
could basically one-shot these carriers
hello [ __ ] four steps he's gotta
commit so overwhelming the airplane of
stats and
for the last 20 years Koreans have
dominated the Starcraft scene this was
the first time in Star cups history that
of non-korean actually won a Blizzcon
championship not to mention that he also
scooped up the GSL versus the World
Championship all for WCS circuits and
just had like the most amazing year 2018
was the year that underdogs made their
names known in eSports they took every
game every scene every eSport by storm
they may not have won everything but
they did make things more exciting and
that means 2019 is said to be one of the
most interesting years that eSports has
ever seen
[Music]
[Music]
I'm gonna do the name
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button
[Music]